فينيسيوس جونيور
صرخه طفل حركت العالم ضد العنصريه في
الليغا لا تستقل ابدا بكلمتك ان كنت لاعب
كره قدم مشهور ربما ادرك الجميع هذه
الرساله بعد ان صرخ فينيسيوس جونيور في
وجه العنصريه سواء من يطلقها او من يرضى
بها ويتغافل انا اسف ولكن الليغا اصبحت
بطوله عنصريه ونحن في البرازيل اصبحنا نرى
اسبانيا كدوله عنصريه بالطبع لم تكن هذه
الكلمات سهله اطلاقا للاعب يلعب في الدوري
الاسباني ولكن الشجاعه التي تحلى بها
فينيسيوس لينطق بذلك اثمرت سريعا فينيسيوس
كان حلقه في سلسله اللاعبين الذين اشتكوا
من العنصريه في الملاعب الاسبانيه على
مدار سنوات ليفتح الباب امام التدخل
لايقاف ذلك الان
حارس مرمى ريوفايكانو ويلفريد اجابوناف
داري تعرض لهتافات عنصريه في
1993 من قبل جماهير ريال مدريد ولكن في
ذلك الوقت لم يكن هناك نفس القدر من
مواجهه تلك السلوكيات روبرتو كارلوس عانى
من ذلك في 1997 في مباراه بين برشلونه
وريال مدريد وتحدث عن تعرضه لهتافات
عنصريه في مقطع فيديو نشره فينيسيوس نفسه
بعد الواقعه الاخيره للتاكيد على امتداد
الظاهره التاريخيا في الليغا وفي 2005
تعرض الكاميروني صامويل ايتو لهتافات
عنصريه في ملعب ساراقوسطه وفقد اعصابه
وكاد يغادر الملعب لولا تهدئه زملائه
ومنافسه له
كارلوس كمان حارس اسبانيول السابق واجه
ذلك على مدار سنوات بصمت ايضا وجماهير
اسبانيول نفسها فعلت الامر ذاته مع انياكي
ويليامز لعب اتلتيكو بلباو وتسبب الامر في
منع 12 من مشجعيه من دخول الملعب في 2020
فضلا عن الحادثه الاشهر حين تعرض داني
الفيش في 2014 لقذف موزه في ملعب
السيراميكا الخاص بنادي فياريال قبل ان
يلتقطها وياكلها دون تعليق ورغم تباين
ردود الافعال في هذه اللقطات وفي عشرات
اللقطات الاخرى التي لم تاخذ حقها من
الزخم الاعلامي نظرا لعدم اهتمام الضحايا
والاعلام والجماهير الا ان الازمه دائما
كانت في مرور كل ذلك دون عقاب ودون محاسبه
للجماهير ولا الانديه التي قامت جماهيرها
بذلك لذلك اكتسبت صرخه فينيسيوس قيمتها
حيث تحدث عنه رئيس البرازيل لدى سيلفا
منتقدا تعرض فتى فقير حقق احلامه واصبح
احد افضل لاعبي العالم الى ذلك الهجوم
العنصري في القرن الحادي والع
لياخذ الامر بعدا دبلوماسيا يتخطى كره
القدم وتتحرك اخيرا مبادره حقيقيه لابعاد
العنصريين عن ملاعب كره القدم والتنديد
بتلك السلوكيات التي يمارسها بعض جمهور
الدوري الاسباني ولهذا ايضا احتاج العالم
لصرخه فينيسيوس في وجه العنصريه ليتحرك
رئيس رابطه الليغا ورئيس الاتحاد الاسباني
وكل المسؤولين عن كره القدم في اسبانيا
خوفا على سمعتها ويدركون ان عليهم بالتحرك
من اجل ايقاف تلك المشاهد المؤسفه والتي
من المفترض الا يكون لها تواجد في ملاعب
كره القدم ولا في اي مسرح من مسارح
الرياضه
[موسيقى]